Oh candy canes are kind of lame I like
anything's I'm very Pro candy canes
I don't like hard things in my mouth I
feel like it just stays old it tastes
like the 70s you're gonna get money
penis can make it herb penis candy yeah
I hope it's not salmon or something
weird I'm getting like earthiness from
it
he's like dirt property no actually no
but I would say like I'm macchiato tuna
Oh bacon it tastes like the blandest
bacon I've ever had it tastes like the
flavor of gristle okay goodness I keep
licking it but I don't like it it smells
like the beach it to me this smells like
an airport hangar don't taste like
anything
wait for it yeah take it out of your
mouth sticky oh oh wow
this is a spicy one a big red candy cane
mixed with a jalapeno is this like a
sriracha candy cane what kind of evil
yeah did this okay whoever made this
definitely is not even this is two
things that I don't like teaming up to
ruin my day probably gonna be I can
guess apparently lime it smells like
beef I'm starting to get a flavor yeah
it tastes like vomit to me experiment if
this is kale I'm gonna smack some beet
Brussels sprout is your booger and you
school on it
Jesus I'm trying to figure out what it
is it's dill dill pickle who is coming
up with this nightmare
yeah I like the whole experience of a
pickle like the crunch the taste the
flavor and this is just a fraction of
the experience
no like a straight up foot Oh yep I got
it
without spicy pepperoni
whoa whoa yeah this is wasabi huh which
one's worse the wasabi or sriracha oh
this is way worse wasabi is not that bad
what's obviated delicious I think candy
canes should remain as decorations and
they should not be eaten if they are not
flavored like Miss I'm really scared to
have one now they're fun to look at but
I don't want them in my mouth
you're Scrooge not all the candy canes
are just one big dad joke my body is
like what did you just put in me and why
did you do it
that's don't